[Music]
this on sharpness is mind boggling the
universe splits in two to revolutionize
our understanding of the universe of the
future right so there's no doubt and no
one's gonna dispute that there is a
mathematical formalism that we know how
to drive
predictions from and those predictions
can be accurate to fourteen decimal
places but what a theory is what a
physical theory is is more than just a
mathematical formalism with some rules
it should specify a physical ontology
which means tell me what exists in the
physical world are there particles are
there fields is there space-time and
tell me about those things and then
specify some laws about how they behave
that tell me how they behave through
time and the problem is that there is
standard quantum what's taught as
quantum theory isn't isn't a theory in
that sense it's just the formalism and
then what people call interpreting
quantum theory which sounds like a funny
thing to do because you'd say well I
have a theory what's an interpretation
what's called interpreting quantum
theory is really the development of
precise physical theories that make the
same predictions or nearly the same
predictions that you get out of this
standard mathematical recipe and so this
to me clears up a kind of funny question
because often they say oh of physicists
would say well I've got quantum theory
what do I need an interpretation for let
the philosophers do the interpreting
whatever that is and that's because the
language is misleading them no you don't
have a theory you have a predictive
recipe and what we want as a physicist
what you should want is a theory is
something that makes clear statements
about what the world is
so in the started with a story about in
South Africa the kuru Hawk there were
dinosaurs there and a kid someone went
up to the caretaker and said how old is
that dinosaur and he said well it's 2
million and 32 years old he said oh how
do you know that he said when I came
here 32 years ago just turn and we just
heard the other day from the Planck
satellite the universe is 13.8 to
billion years old or large the 21st well
it's not 2 months in tinder days older
than it and the point is time progresses
and the key points which I'm going to
say which a lot of physicists denies
that the past the present and the future
are completely different from each other
the past has happened it's fixed it's
determined and there's nothing you can
do about that the future is
indeterminate we don't know what's going
to happen and the present is where the
change takes place from the
indeterminate future to the determinist
past now one of the things about that of
course is some people claim that physics
will determine the future this is goes
back to the plus and their various
things they haven't taken into account
one of them is quantum uncertainty which
we can talk about but the other of
course is the fact that physics does not
actually by itself determine everything
it happens for instance that glass of
water there what does physics say is
going to be the future position of that
loss of water in 10 seconds time well
the answer is physics doesn't Lucas
actually it is where physics does not
predict it must be 10 seconds ago and so
physics is a partial explanation to
what's going on in the universe but it's
not a total explanation the past
influence is the present and the future
and so the past exists you have to say
it exists because it affects what's
happening now if we didn't say the past
exists we would have to say something
which didn't exist affects what happened
today so the past does exist because it
influences what happens today the future
does not exist because it isn't yet
determinate now quantum uncertainty is
there at the foundations of physics and
the point about us is it affects what
happens at the macroscopic scale so I'll
give you two examples if you knew
everything about what happened on the
surface of the earth four billion years
you couldn't predict that we would exist
or that giraffes would exist today and
the reason is because cosmic rays have
influenced our genetic history they've
changed the structure of DNA in a way
which has changed evolutionary history
and I'm a commission of a cosmic ray
photon is a quantum uncertain event
again because those were quantum
fluctuations even in principle if you
knew everything about the universe about
13 billion years ago you couldn't
predict that we would exist that our
galaxy would exist today let alone the
earth therefore you couldn't predict
even in principle that you or I or
anything in this room would exist so the
future is not determined at the present
time it unfolds as it happens and the
way it will happen unfold is not
determined because that's a foundational
thing we discovered about quantum
physics last century let's take a look
classically what we know is that objects
have definite properties so for example
if you want to describe a neutron you
can for instance say that a neutron is
at a particular position zero or it's in
a different position one these two
positions are distinguishable you can
also assign an energy to the neutral and
lots of other properties spin etc and
they're all definite quantum
mechanically picture is completely
different there is a state where the
neutron is in position zero does it say
it where the neutron is in position one
but also there is this particular state
here which I represent pictorially like
that where we can only predict the
probability for the neutron to be in
position 0 or 1 but the position is
unsharp and these states are called
super positions and notice that these
unsharp ness has nothing to do or is
very little to do with stochastic
uncertainty like when you throw a dice
this is a different type of and
sharpness is richer and this is why it's
the key property that powers all of
quantum mechanics
features including those that are used
for quantum computers for quantum
cryptography and for pop for properties
like entanglement there are extreme
exotic and different for what we
perceive now this on sharpness is mind
boggling it's a very beautiful feature
of these quantum systems but it's also a
source of very interesting problems and
one of the most interesting problems
comes up when we try to ascribe the Sun
sharpness to objects which are demanded
by other physical theories to be sharp
all the time and this is the case of
gravity quantum mechanics is first of
all a theory which is correct so I'm not
going to put any doubt on the
fundamental correct nature of the theory
it's an absolutely the brilliant
discovery made in the early 20th century
the 1920s in 1920s physicists discovered
that there's a very special way of
addressing the motion and other
properties of the tiniest particles in
this universe the atoms the molecules
the photons whatever unit name where
this small tiny and light it is
controlled by a very remarkable set of
equations science called quantum
mechanics so what was then discovered
immediately afterwards is that quantum
mechanics is correct I still remember
when I was a student of physics of
course that was much later that I when I
learned about electrons
I thought quantum mechanics was a theory
for electrons whereas there are other
particles notably the nucleus of an atom
which look totally different
so I remember the surprise I had and
people said of course that also must be
controlled by quantum mechanics so I
said why otherwise it doesn't work
it doesn't make any sense and of course
soon enough and I learn more about the
mathematics of quantum mechanics and
realize this must be the case the entire
world is controlled by quantum mechanics
so I completely agree with the equations
and also with what happened after that
as soon as quantum mechanics was
discovered people realized there was a
fundamental difficulty with answering
the question what it means what is a
subatomic particle what is a photon what
is a molecule how these things behave
where we know how they behave describe
the quantum mechanics but the question
which was not properly answered was what
is reality so there were heated
discussions not only being between these
people here you see a newsboy Aaron
Schrodinger and then a Heisenberg but
also iron stein and many others were
present in these discussions and there
are heated discussions about what
quantum mechanics really was whether it
makes sense or not and they reach an
agreement and the agreement was yes this
theory makes sense and also many many
technical agreements about how to do the
calculations how these particles move
how to do a calculation how can you
predict the outcome of an experiment and
they finally all agreed about that and I
agree about that too but then there was
one thing they said and there I don't
agree the thing they said is and now
there's this question about what is it
really doesn't really mean what is a
particle what is a field and so on your
killer asked questions of this sort
where is the position of the particle
where what is its velocity or its
momentum and then the answers become
confusing so what the people who had
these discussions in Copenhagen in
Denmark where news war had this famous
institute at that time and used war was
a center of these discussions in a sense
what they said is well you just don't
ask such questions don't ask what it
really really means just ask what the
equations are and ask how you do the
calculations and that's all you need to
know that is true it's all
need to know if you want to know what
the theory really predicts but if you
want to know what's really going on they
don't get an answer and so their
agreement was don't ask that question
and works perfectly now here however I
disagree I disobey I am asking that
question which she said it's a forbidden
question I won't know what it is that's
really going on I refuse to accept ideas
that have been put forward more and more
in later times about the fuzziness of
reality about the they are not existing
one universe but a whole multitude of
different worlds that describe all the
possible outcomes of a quantum
calculation also the idea that I must
have some pilot waves as was proposed at
the time that the Scot that prescribed
particles how to move it can't be right
the beliefs that are still holding up I
was the idea that there should be a real
world describing universe that should be
just one universe one universe
containing particles people planets
stars galaxies they all really exist
it's not true that you have to be vague
about reality but if you say such a
thing
then you place yourself a little bit
outside of the main discussion area
where people were so happy this idea
that something fuzzy about a reality I'm
not happy with that idea at all so
quantum mechanics what does it say it
tells you how to handle these statistics
of particles it doesn't tell you how one
single particle behaves it's very
confusing about that but if you do
experiments with millions of particles
or you take one experiment and you
repeat it a million times on the same
particle then it becomes very precise
and C gets very accurate calculations
compares a little bit with the insurance
company the insurance company cannot
predict at all when you will die or
whether or not you will have an accident
but it does note if you have million
people or a thousand
people then you know which percentage
will die and during which time periods
and it will know which percentage of
these people will have an accident and
that's all they care about
to determine the costs often insurance
so in that sense quantum mechanics works
as accurately as what would be needed by
an insurance company
[Music]
teleportation this is really science
fiction matter cannot jump you cannot
start here disappear here and appear in
another place it's just against all
physical laws however quantum mechanics
tell us that there is no need to move
matter because we are all made out of
electrons protons and all electrons are
the same this what quantum mechanics
tell us identical particles there is no
any difference between electrons and my
body intellectual in this table so all
what we need we really to move have to
move the shape how this particles
arranged in quantum mechanics the shape
is a wavefunction so all what we have to
move is a wavefunction from one place to
another we don't need to move objects
and this is what have to be done there
is a matter here there is a matter here
all what we have to do is just to chain
to create out of the matter here what
was me before so many signs supposed to
explain everything and explaining the K
in if science can really explain it in a
causality form this would be the best
situation and causality is the real
canary causation causation that things
are moved because they pushed local and
also things are deterministic everything
is determined by this state is now and
my research
quantum mechanics allows me to believe
that I understand nature at large I
think physics today explains everything
everything is deterministic and this
motion of this thing is also also
explained by physics because I myself is
also explained by physics that you
explained by physics so the physics
initially your initial condition tells
us why why you moved so physics explain
everything now so it's uncertainty
quantum mechanics very famous concept oh
yeah I don't like it I was looking for
danger and I there is it's very strange
phenomena you measure something here and
this changes something there there are
two things first it's non-local second
it's random then you measure it here you
don't know what will happen this forces
me to believe in particular
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which is the many-worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics it means that every
time I make a quantum measurement which
might come out differently all outcomes
happened but this makes things
deterministic on the level of universe I
feel like I got a particular result but
really what happened I got this result
and another copy of me got another
result in the physical universe
everything remained I just became a to
copy of me and then the copy of me which
found this result well later
go there and find the opposite result of
quantum correlation so on the level on
the physical universe everything
deterministic and everything in a sense
local like every change in physics
happened really locally this we
understand in classical mechanics I
touch it it moves in quantum mechanics
this difference complicate effects like
interference
I can put particles through two slits
and then when it and then it might come
this way use this way in there are
strange days closes little when both are
open
I cannot come here one is closed it can
come here this interference effect this
interference effect I also can explain
locally what I believe are no particles
everything waves electrons waves
billiard balls of waves i'ma wait if I'm
a waves then of course I do interference
and the wave influence of F is local the
particle goes around it's wave split in
two there are two wave packets one here
and one here and then here locally there
are fields which push this particle and
pushed this part of the party they come
together if this was pushed a little
faster the interference will be
different now in physics
apart from this nonlocality uncertainty
which I resolved by many word
interpretation there is another
nonlocality I run off bomb type it was
told that if I can make this
interference experiment with two slits
and put something in the middle which
doesn't put any field outside and then I
can change this interference and this
this effect of in fact was my adviser
for fifty and he discovered it wasn't
fifty years are not bomb effect and now
I came against him
I found a local explanation of this
effect to believe that everything is
local in deterministic on the level of
the physical unit
Mike what are your views well the
arrival of quantum theory at the
beginning of the last century was a
radical departure from the deterministic
clockwork universe of Isaac Newton
according to the Newtonian view if we
knew the speed and position of every
particle in the universe we could
predict the future at least in principle
now quantum mechanics put a stop to all
that according to the traditional
interpretation of quantum mechanics the
so-called Copenhagen interpretation
developed by Niels Bohr and others in
the 20s and 30s we cannot predict with
certainty the outcome of any experiment
the best we can do is to assign a
probability so for example let's suppose
we have an experiment with two possible
outcomes call them a and B and we know
that the probabilities of a is 70% let's
say and B 30%
what that means is if we perform the
experiment a hundred times then a will
happen roughly 70 times and B will
happen roughly 30 times but we cannot
predict any individual outcome now this
is not because of any defect of the
apparatus or any lack of knowledge on
our part it's the way nature is we don't
need to apologize for this this view has
survived a hundred years of rigorous
theoretical and experimental scrutiny so
my view is if it ain't broke don't fix
it now it gives rise to unusual states
of affairs of course there's the famous
Schrodinger paradox where the cat can be
70% alive and 30% dead at the same time
because again according to the
traditional view the two possibilities a
and B coexist until we choose to make a
measurement on the system and it's the
very act of making that measurement that
forces the reality to be either one or
the other and that's what Schrodinger
was highlighting with his cat that was
both alive and dead now some people who
are dissatisfied with this
interpretation again I don't think this
dissatisfaction extends to a
disagreement with experiment every
experiment that's ever been performed is
perfectly consistent with this
traditional view it's rather a
discomfort that people feel with the
notion of uncertainty one example of
this was Hugh Everett in the 1950s he
didn't like this idea of uncertainty and
he proposed that at each moment of
measurement the universe splits into two
one in one universe outcome a happens in
the other the universe outcome B and so
as we proceed there are infinitely
branching in many many different
universes now not everybody liked
Everett's interpretation and in fact the
main objection was that it was just that
an interpretation he wasn't changing the
predictions of the theory if we want to
calculate the spectrum of the hydrogen
atom or the decay of a radioactive
nucleus both approaches would give you
the same answer and that's the weakness
in a way of the alternatives
unless according to a physicist unless
your theory is giving you different
experimental predictions it's not worth
drawing any distinction between the
conventional theory and your
interpretation if it's just a matter of
interpretation that's of no consequence
what matters is the prediction
so my view I suppose would be the
stick-in-the-mud view that the theory we
have is doing very nicely thank you I
feel many ideas in Street theory which
our deeds are precisely of that type
that cannon in my opinion should be
shared with the broader public string
theory is trying to explain what we are
made of how the universe works at the
most fundamental level what are the
basic ingredients what are the forces
between particles how did the universe
come to me what does it black hole work
what is the future of the universe all
for us all the deep questions that
everybody wants to know it's kind of
like yeah of course I want to know that
does this feel a thing
do you say about them and indeed
studious begin it has begun to offer a
some some context into terms of which we
can begin to answer these deep questions
for example we have learned that the the
matter in the universe is all unified
into one that unity is quite amazing and
that's what's one of the elegant things
each other
once sounds philosophical at the same
time is unifying crystal explaining all
of physics so while one must might think
that all this sounds like very just
wishful thinking about aesthetic this
has come out to be real in the context
of string can be realized so so they are
fortunate to be having such a structure
where it potentially explains everything
around us in terms of this unifying
picture in terms of how the matter all
comes together how the forces get
unified and how that comes to describe
the geometry of space and time
others instantly hit with quantum
mechanics how do the black holes come to
the picture how the Big Bang work what's
going to happen in the future
all them together from the smallest to
the biggest
from how the forces work too hard
everything macroscopic we behave so that
sounds like a very big fairyland
yes where has your work taking you
within that so my work actually has been
has been related to different aspects of
this field
I have been interested in in
mathematical and geometrical on their
paintings of this subject how the string
theory work we have learned that in the
context of string theory the dimension
of the space-time is not just three
spatial on one temporal direction but
also it has extra dimensions
next your dimensions are new in physics
and what do they have to offer what why
don't we see these extra dimensions
around us well because they are tiny and
if they are tiny it's hard to see them
in the experiments but even though they
are tiny turns out what sheet they have
and what how many holes they have or
exactly those details turn out to impact
the things we see around us like how
many particles we have what are the
forces what are the masses of particles
and all these gets related to these tiny
geometries that we don't see so
translating geometry to observable
things around us the forces the
particles is is what is one of the areas
I have been most interested in in this
subject physics isn't in trouble I think
we have a really healthy way in which
our scientific process works in physics
maybe because I'm in particle physics
and it's operating successfully but we
have theories that try and understand
reality we have data that is our
interpretation of reality we confront
the theories with data to winnow out
those interpretations that match reality
from those that don't and equally we
have the underlying theory to give our
experimental observations context to
make them meaningful and that's very
important these two approaches go hand
in hand now in the introduction to this
session you encouraged us to perhaps to
consider multiverses and string theory
as bad science I think that's really
unfair I think that in terms of
developing our theoretical understanding
and providing tools that can benefit all
manner of theoretical investigations
they're extremely good theoretical
science and that imagination that allows
you to step back from the straitjacket
of our current understanding where as
Davis says we're limited there are
things that we know experimentally in
the universe that we cannot explain with
our existing understanding you have to
get out of that mindset to make progress
you need imagination and this is where
string theory and multiverse start to
come in to fill the gap okay they're
nowhere near making predictions yet so
as an experimentalist I like to sit back
and think well it's a great
I love it but I can't test it so it's an
idea it's not the theory yet but in
order to make progress you need a whole
spectrum of understanding you need your
current understanding that works you
need the list of holes in it so for
example dark matter the behavior of
antimatter the unification of gravity
without the rest of our understanding
these are all big issues for us you need
the theories that try and plug the gap
coming yeah
more more speculative I grant you but
progress will be made theoretically and
one of these is or well may may pay off
and extend our understanding and that's
invaluable so you can't dismiss it I
mean really we don't know what's going
to come out just because a theory is not
predictive in the future doesn't mean to
say it's not going to yield something
fantastic and revolutionize our
understanding of the universe in the
future so I think we're healthy and we
should go on being healthy I think it
might be useful just just to give you
all a sense of perspective about about
where physics is right now what we know
what what we don't know I think physics
is really healthy I think you can take
your kickin concern to the slightest um
you know the question was you know
experimental theory should we
concentrate on one more than the other
as far as I can tell we're focusing all
our efforts on both of these and they're
both equally important there's some
areas of physics where we do very well
where the theory is very strong the
experiments is very strong and they just
fit together perfectly so the great
example is particle physics the question
- what are we all made of at the most
fundamental level we have this amazing
theory of physics it's by far the best
theory in the history of science we give
it a rubbish name we call it the
standard model but it predicts every
single experiment we've ever done in a
particle accelerator predicts the result
with in some cases unprecedented
accuracy some cases two to ten decimal
places you know you do the calculation
you do the theory you do the experiment
they just match perfectly one digit
after the other so that that's really
you know a poster boy for what science
should look like then there's other
areas of physics like cosmology but how
did the universe start what
began the universe and we just don't
know the answer to that that's that's
very simple but we do know what was
happening for sure 10 to the minus 20
seconds after the beginning of the
universe that's pretty impressive and we
really understand very very well what
was going on experimentally and
theoretically and we think we understand
what was going on 10 to the minus 30
seconds after the beginning of the Big
Bang there's a theory called inflation
which over the last 15 years has just
got very very compelling experimental
evidence that this is whoops what's
happening so again I think I think we're
very well set in in in understanding
these two areas then there are areas of
physics and john you mentioned string
theory where we don't yet have any
experimental evidence whatsoever the
questions that we're asking are hard
questions and we haven't built
experiments to test them yet so instead
you have to rely on logic have to rely
on mathematical consistency is it
possible to write down a mathematical
theory that includes both quantum
mechanics and gravity the answer turns
out to be yes it took us 20 years to
figure this out and in the subsequent 30
years we still haven't really understood
this this theory we still haven't really
understood what it's about because
because it's hard so there are these
very difficult questions and john you
said never we can never test string
theory
Nevers a long long time I don't know
when we're gonna test string theory I
don't know if it's gonna be in the next
10 years it may not even be in my
lifetime but the questions we're trying
to answer is so important that we've got
to try you know you've got to have a go
at figuring out what's happening
so supersymmetry
as far as we can tell is an essential
feature of this theory called string
theory which is for my mind the only
serious candidate we have an
all-encompassing theory of everything so
I think if we found evidence for
supersymmetry then the next item on the
agenda would be to try to find some sort
of positive evidence for string theory
one way or another but that looks pretty
tough
how does string theory provide a
explanation of everything so string
theory is a framework which combines the
force of gravity general relativity with
all the other fundamental interactions
that operate at the level of elementary
particles so string theory can put
gravity together with electricity and
magnetism for example or the forces that
exist inside the nucleus and I just
don't know of any other theories that
can do that and the other thing about
string theory is that it provides a
framework where you can make a true
quantum theory of gravity so I think
it's that no a great embarrassment to
theoretical physicists that over a
century after Einstein wrote down the
general theory of relativity and since
people developed quantum mechanics we
still are looking for a theory that
combines these two different areas of
physics it's a tough problem but string
theory provides a solution and there's
various indirect pieces of evidence of
that that's the right way to go but we
would really like to find some more
solid evidence in favor of string theory
so what about string theory well the
problem is that it's about 40 years
since string theory was first
hypothesized and in that time it's been
worked on by 90% of theoretical
physicists working at the frontiers of
fundamental physics and yet during that
time it's so far not made any
independently testable predictions
there's no experiment that you can talk
about where the string theory is said do
this experiment and this is the number
that you'll get and then people did the
experiment and got the number and let's
just appreciate how what what the
standard that we hold scientific
theories to hear especially theories in
physics the idea is not you know you
just predict this or that no I do is you
predict something to ten decimal places
and you predict exactly what's going to
happen and general relativity does it
predicts the orbit of the planets to an
incredible accuracy quantum
electrodynamics predicts to an
incredible accuracy the the the light
that's emitted by atoms when you excite
them but string theory so far nothing
like that but that hasn't stopped lots
of visits saying this is scientific
knowledge and there's something that
goes with string theory which people
also say we know which is the idea of
supersymmetry and supersymmetry says for
all the particles in nature that we
found they should have a kind of twin
and none of those twin particles have
been found but supersymmetry has to be
true for string theory to work now for
some people that means there must be
supersymmetry and they reason as follows
string Theory's true string theory
implies supersymmetry therefore those
supersymmetry so
I think John anise has said this we live
in a supersymmetric universe but there's
no direct evidence of supersymmetry
there are other theories that posit
supersymmetry other than string theory
and each time a new particle accelerator
has been developed there have been
people who've said now we're going to
see the evidence because we finally got
to the energy where supersymmetry should
show up and then when they haven't
detected it they've said what we've
learned is that supersymmetry only
applies that an even higher energy that
when we thought now so many people that
sounds like exactly the kind of saving
your theory from refutation by making an
arbitrary modification of it that
characterize is not being scientific so
what's going on well one thing that's
going on is a big fight in theoretical
physics so and you should be aware of
course that physics is a vast subject
and most physicists don't work on
fundamental physics at all lots of
physicists work on condensed matter and
electromagnetism and classical mechanics
and all sorts of things and the vast
majority of them don't say anything
about string theory and they don't
believe it
but in in the community of people
working on fundamental physics string
theory is this seems to have the status
of truth or what we should believe so
some physicists wrote a letter to nature
saying this is no good you guys are
forgetting what makes the scientific
method the scientific method you're
forgetting what makes science different
from other forms of belief we don't want
to say that string Theory's unscientific
it's a really good hypothesis it's worth
working on it's got a lot going for it
but we should distinguish between
something like that a hypothesis
has a lot going for it that we ought to
work on from what's known what's what
what's part of established scientific
knowledge and so they say you guys are
doing a disservice to science by telling
people that we know that there are
strings we know the world's made of
strings and for that matter
another example telling people that
there are parallel universes because one
of the things that string theory seems
to require according to some people is
that there be many many universes
because there's so many different string
theories you've got to explain why we
have the one that we have rather than
all the others and when they say well we
don't just have this one we have all the
other ones too but there in other
universes that we don't have access to
so besides those experimental findings
there's been also a revolution in in
theoretical physics part of it is
related to recent discoveries about nine
years ago in string theory now we don't
have an underlying theory of everything
but swing theory is the closest we can
get at the moment perhaps it's right or
perhaps it's wrong we will know at some
point but right now that's the one that
makes the most sense when we study
systems like the universe and energies
where all the other theories like the
Einstein theory breaks down so we have
got to take string theory seriously what
what string theory is found was that
once you start with eleven dimensions
which is how the story goes in string
theory and you try to wrap up those
extra seven dimensions the reason is
because eventually you just want to
produce the universe like ours
we've only got three space plus one time
dimension height width and length and
the time direction so you mathematically
you can start it as many dimensions as
you like but eventually you have to make
sure somehow you reduce those extra
dimensions and and end up with a world
that has only three space plus one time
dimension and that's the exercise that
string theories did for for at least two
decades they were hoping that if string
theory is on the right track due to
being a fundamental theory then once
they knew they
exhausted all possible mathematical ways
of getting rid of the extra dimensions
and ending up with with a three plus one
dimensional universe then they would end
up with only one and and that what that
was one of the most beautiful examples
for damage prejudice can do in science
the reason why we all wanted to end up
for this string theory or even quantum
mechanics previously we all wanted that
underlying theory to end up with just
one universe is because the multiverse
was considered a bad taste concept and
and of course nature wouldn't care about
what what we like or or what we think
because it throw another surprise at us
what string theory is discovered after
an enormous mathematical exercise was
that if you do this exercise of wrapping
up that the way you get rid of extra
dimensions is by wrapping crawling them
up to make them really small so they are
invisible to ask do two large creatures
and and that works its say if you make
the extra dimensions really
microscopical and even smaller then you
have gotten rid of them they they just
dumped some energy in in the remaining
three space plus one-time dimensions but
for all practical purposes we won't know
they are around so one string theorist
managed to carry out that process they
discovered that you end up with many
with an almost infinite number of
universes that look just like ours that
have three space plus one time dimension
and and at the time that's the about
2002-2003 at the time that was
considered the death of string theory
evil string Theory's themselves were
quite seriously concerned about about
this finding that was dubbed the
landscape of string theory because it
seemed like the theory lost itself
falsifiability
if you predict so many possible
universes well then anything you observe
in the sky you'll always go and find the
matter on that landscape of some
universe that has an observable that
looks like the one you just sit
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institutes of
arson ideas at IAI TV
[Music]